llegó a berlín el avión medicalizado que
transportaba al opositor ruso alexéi
navalni quien se encuentra en coma
inducido en medio de sospechas de haber
sido envenenado tras arduas
negociaciones las autoridades de rusia
permitieron su traslado para ser tratado
en un hospital alemán
con la tasa más alta de contagios a
nivel global y en medio de reclamos de
reapertura económica la pandemia de
coronavirus sigue golpeando américa
latina' en colombia los sectores del
turismo la aviación y la hotelería
exigieron una reapertura completa
mientras los decesos van en aumento
demandas que se replican en varias
naciones de la región
y los devastadores incendios en
california se duplicaron y dejan al
momento al menos 6 muertos además de
decenas de personas heridas y cientos de
viviendas destruidas el gobernador del
estado pidió ayuda internacional a
canadá y australia además de a unos 10
estados de su país
muy buenos días bienvenidos a una nueva
emisión informativa de france 24
saludamos a nuestra audiencia muchas
gracias por acompañarnos y santiago
ariztía y estas son las noticias el
avión en el que era transportado el
líder opositor ruso alexéi navalni
aterrizó este sábado en berlín alemania
para recibir tratamiento médico y es que
el líder se encuentra en coma inducido y
sus seguidores aseguran que fue
posiblemente envenenado con un té que
habría bebido en el aeropuerto de la
ciudad siberiana de tomsk los médicos
rusos descartaron que haya sido
envenenado pero permitieron que sea
trasladado los detalles los tiene
valentina torres sánchez
así fue como el líder opositor ruso
alexéi navalni llegó al hospital de
berlín en el que ya recibe tratamiento
médico
y despegó en un avión medicalizado desde
homs donde estaba hospitalizado desde el
jueves luego de desmayarse en el avión
que lo trasladaba desde tomsk a moscú de
acuerdo con sus seguidores el opositor
fue envenenado probablemente con un té
que tomo en el aeropuerto de tomsk por
lo que la aeronave en la que viajaba
aterrizó de emergencia en omsk su salida
de rusia se produjo en medio de una
amplia polémica en principio los médicos
aseguraban que no era recomendable
trasladarlo porque el despegue y el
aterrizaje podían causar consecuencias
sin embargo el viaje fue autorizado tras
la presión ejercida por sus seguidores y
su esposa que se dirigió oficialmente al
presidente putin
para que se detenga y exclusión
el diagnóstico de envenenamiento fue
definitivamente descartado con base en
análisis químico toxicológicos
el equipo médico ruso consideró que el
paciente puede ser transportado ellos
señalaron que el transporte es posible y
garantizaron que lo llevaran a un
destino específico que es berlín
esto nos lo enseña
según los médicos rusos el estado del
opositor se debe a un trastorno
metabólico versión que fue rechazada por
su doctora personal tanto francia como
alemania habían expresado su
preocupación por el estado de salud de
nava al cni y se habían ofrecido a
tratarlo el opositor ya había sufrido un
envenenamiento el año pasado cuando
cumplía un arresto administrativo doctor
y permanecemos en alemania pero lo
hacemos para hablar ahora de la pandemia
de coronavirus en este país que en medio
de un aumento diario de contagios
registró más de 2.000 nuevos casos en
las últimas 24 horas la última vez que
el número fue mayor a esta nueva cifra
fue en el pasado mes de abril según las
autoridades del país el incremento
estaría vinculado al regreso de turistas
de sus vacaciones en zonas de riesgo del
extranjero el instituto robert koch
encargado de la vigilancia
epidemiológica en el país registró 2 mil
34 nuevos casos lo que eleva a 232 mil
82 en total de contagios desde que
comenzó la pandemia
y en otras noticias la organización
mundial de la salud prevé que la
pandemia de kobe 19 dure casi 2 años en
medio de alertas por posibles rebrotes
en europa y mientras regiones de américa
latina' registran un incremento diario
de contagios tras casi cinco meses de
confinamiento el organismo indicó este
viernes que espera que la pandemia dure
menos de dos años el director general de
la oms advirtió que para acabar con el
brote es necesaria la coordinación de
esfuerzos internacionales en abertis
advantage tenemos la desventaja de la
globalización la cercanía y la
conectividad pero también tenemos la
ventaja de una mejor tecnología
de spanair así que esperamos terminar
esta pandemia antes de dos años atrás
especially especialmente si podemos unir
nuestros esfuerzos con unidad nacional y
solidaridad global esa es la clave con
la utilización de las herramientas
disponibles al máximo y la esperanza de
que podemos tener herramientas
adicionales como la vacuna los life
boxing continuamos con información sobre
el avance de coronavirus en américa
latina' de la religión continua muy ágil
debido a la pandemia en colombia a los
sectores del turismo la aviación y la
hotelería exigieron una reapertura
completa y esto en medio del incremento
de las muertes mientras tanto el
gobierno de bolivia adelantó una campaña
de testeo en la ciudad de la paz y esto
para detener la escalada de casos
mientras que argentina anunció el inicio
de ensayos clínicos de la vacuna china y
también otras medidas pero el virus
continúa sin mostrar signos de
retroceder en esta región que tiene la
tasa más altas de contagio a nivel
global
decenas de personas se agolparon a las
afueras del aeropuerto eldorado
desafiando el virus en bogotá pertenecen
a los sectores de la aviación el turismo
y la hotelería que desde el comienzo del
confinamiento del 25 de marzo quedaron
totalmente paralizados exigen una
reapertura económica total en uno de los
países con la cuarentena más larga del
mundo el desempleo es su principal
argumento ya que la desocupación escaló
al 19.8 por ciento en junio la economía
cayó en 15.7 por ciento en el segundo
trimestre del año y los sectores de la
comida el transporte el comercio y el
alojamiento vieron una caída del 34
punto 3% pero la alcaldesa de la capital
anunció una estrategia para reabrir
restaurantes aunque los demás sectores
siguen en suspenso en medio de un
incremento en las muertes en bolivia y
la situación no es distinta el gobierno
lanzó una estrategia de testeo masivo
para cobijar al 43% del área
metropolitana de la paz para hacer
frente a la escalada de contagios
en 1800 personas en 600 brigadas se
espera llegar a 180 mil 180.000 familias
el gobierno argentino entretanto declaró
la televisión el internet y la telefonía
celular como servicios públicos
esenciales y decidió congelar sus
tarifas hasta el 31 de diciembre ante
las restricciones que la pandemia nos
impone nadie deberá resignar parte de
sus ingresos en afrontar aumentos en los
precios de estos servicios además
anunció que iniciará ensayos clínicos de
la vacuna china pero antes había
informado que será el distribuidor junto
a mexico de la prometedora vacuna de
oxford y tal como veíamos en este
informe la pandemia de corona vídeo
golpea con muchísima fuerza américa
latina' con tres de las naciones más
afectadas de todo el mundo entre ellas
perú la segunda más golpeada de la
región que se acerca ya a los 600.000
casos esta nación sudamericana está
cerca a ser uno de los países con la
tasa más alta de mortalidad tras haber
sobrepasado la barrera de los 27 mil
decesos a nivel global el país es el
sexto con más contagios
a nivel de decesos según cifras de la
universidad johns hopkins y para conocer
más de cerca la situación en perú sobre
el brote de coronavirus vamos a
comunicarnos con ciro maguiña eres
médico infectólogo señor marín ya
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france en 24 preguntarle en primer lugar
a qué atribuye no esta alta tasa de
decesos en perú
obedece pues que el perú para hice una
crisis histórica salita es de 50 años y
eso paga factura junto que el enfoque
básicamente ese hospitalario el enfoque
comunitario es el que no se ha
enfrentado desde hace semanas del
colegio médico yo soy vice decano del
colegio médico ha participado
activamente en sugerencias del estado
del control comunitario con pruebas con
aislamiento etcétera no funcionaba en
gran parte de perú y se explica la alta
morbimortalidad
ahora ha trascendido que existiría un
subregistro en perú y que las víctimas
mortales podrían ser más de 60.000 es
esto así usted maneja esta información
no es al contrario creo que hemos sido
sincerando en estos semanas y meses y
las cifras que tenemos es porque mente
lo que ustedes tienen tal vez faltarán
unos cuantos ajustes pero es la realidad
digamos sin exagerar que sea 100 serán
las últimas semanas por lo tanto
enfrentamos consecuencias del sistema el
sistema atrasado en todos los temas
igual que en américa latina que no se
salvan ni siquiera en países
desarrollados y este económico pues paga
factura como decíamos de nantes y
tenemos que insistir en el enfoque
comunitario que es vital para contener
esta enfermedad que es como una maratón
que no termina prontamente señor marín
ya trascendió también que hay una alta
demanda de oxígeno en perú que estarían
instalando también plantas en los
próximos meses cómo están manejando
estas
situación cuál es el escenario en este
sentido bueno la oferta con la demanda
del oxígeno sea dos veces pago factura
en la amazonía en el oriente peruano que
es una causa importante de mortalidad y
gran parte del perú así afectado pero
felizmente la empresa privada del estado
está dotando en estas semanas
abasteciendo un abastecimiento incluso
en los municipios que permiten por lo
menos desestabilizar uno de los
problemas graves que es el oxígeno dado
que no hay hoy día pues medicinas en el
mundo y la vacuna que ojalá salga pronto
tiene más una esperanza para el mundo
tampoco no es fácil para países pobres
siempre se queda en los países ricos no
ojalá que la vacuna se reparta bien en
la torta del anti kobe creo que es la
demanda que hacemos y creo que es
injusto que la vacuna solamente se quede
pues en los países poderosos y los
ensayos van a permitir ver que la
genética sirva para diferenciar qué es
resistente o no la vacuna o soy
optimista incendio pero analista en el
tiempo
ciro maguiña muchísimas gracias por esta
comunicación desde la capital peruana
con france24 avanzamos ahora con otras
noticias porque los devastadores
incendios en california eeuu se
incrementaron hasta casi duplicarse y
dejan al momento al menos 6 muertos
además de decenas de personas heridas se
trata de alrededor de 560 focos
incendiarios que destruyeron a cerca de
500 viviendas y otras estructuras
edilicias california solicitó la
colaboración de unos 375 equipos de
bomberos de los cuales cerca de 45 ya
están trabajando en la zona el
gobernador del estado gabino son dijo
que ya pidió ayuda internacional a
canadá y australia además de a unos 10
estados de su país
la concentración del fuego es el desafío
que enfrentamos en el estado ahora está
impactando de manera desproporcionada el
norte de california
eso se debe a cerca de 12.000 rayos que
experimentamos durante un período de 72
horas hace un día anuncie que estamos
luchando para abordar las necesidades de
él
unos 376 incendios en este estado ese
número ha aumentado alrededor de 560 en
el estado de california en 6º fires en
este campo de noticias de américa
latina' una tensa situación se vivió en
uno de los pasos fronterizos entre
colombia y venezuela este viernes en
principio las autoridades colombianas
informaron que el puente había sido
cerrado a causa del alto flujo de
migrantes que buscaban retornar a su
país sin embargo el gobierno de caracas
desmintió la información asegurando que
sólo se estaban realizando una labor de
desinfección y arremetió contra las
autoridades colombianas asegurando que
mienten y desinforman el informe de
valentina torres sánchez
cientos de migrantes venezolanos
permanecieron bloqueados este viernes en
el puente simón bolívar que conecta a
colombia con venezuela en principio las
autoridades colombianas indicaron que
caracas les había informado que había
decidido cerrar el paso fronterizo
debido al alto número de migrantes que
han regresado a su país en los últimos
días en este es a porque sentir que
tiene tenemos nuestro total nuestra
familia allá y está en la tierra de
nosotros sentimos es tristeza porque el
presidente allá no le da la gana de que
nosotros pasemos sin embargo horas
después el presidente nicolás maduro
arremetió contra colombia y aseguró que
en el lugar sólo se estaba realizando
una actividad de desinfección para
prevenir más contagios de joven 19
el gobierno de colombia en sus falsos
positivos mintiendo todos los días sobre
venezuela mintiendo y mintiendo dice que
hemos cerrado los puentes
internacionales que unen a colombia con
venezuela falso falso quedaron como uno
ridículo o sencillamente hubo una
operación de limpieza que duró dos horas
y el mismo se restableció el paso
tranquilamente buscando coloca sólo se
estima que desde marzo cuando colombia
declaró la emergencia sanitaria unos 100
mil migrantes han vuelto a venezuela y
al menos 40.000 se encuentran cerca de
la frontera esperando que las
autoridades de caracas les permitan el
reingreso a su país
y al menos 11 personas fueron masacradas
en colombia en la zona rural de el tambo
ubicada en el departamento del cauca
fueron asesinadas seis personas en un
ataque cuyos autores todavía no han sido
identificados y más temprano en la
defensoría del pueblo informó de la
matanza de cinco personas en una zona
rural de arauca capital del departamento
que lleva el mismo nombre fronterizo con
venezuela colombia recordemos ha visto
sacudida en las últimas semanas por
varias masacres en algunas de las cuales
fueron asesinados menores de edad estas
regiones del país están marcadas por la
presencia de grupos ilegales que se
disputan territorios para los cultivos
de coca
[Música]
utilizamos de esta manera otra emisión
informativa quédense con nosotros hay
mucho más en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]